this is the Staples Center in downtown
Los Angeles
normally you would go there to see
something like this or this or this but
one week this summer a different kind of
act was warming up for their performance
the spectacle that still calls itself
the greatest show on earth Ringling
Brothers is a hundred and forty six
years old we're actually one year older
than baseball so when I was a kid even
Ringling Brothers was very different
than you know the show that I'm
producing today and can you tell me your
name and who you are sure I'm Alana Feld
producer of Brinley Brothers Barnum &
Bailey presents of this world to keep
the circus interesting for a modern-day
audience Alana has added ice skating a
Space Age storyline and the obligatory
integration with social media but maybe
the biggest change here is what's
missing we decided to retire our Asian
elephants why there's been a lot of
bills proposed to ban the bull hook
which is the instrument used to work
with animals how do you feel about that
well I think you know when we made the
decision it was hard because you know I
loved the elephants and I loved seeing
them and Ringling Brothers but we made
the decision to you know keep a lot of
other animals in our show and that's one
that we stand by is that controversial
at all
we have a lot of critics and you know
they choose to you know come out and
show you know their share their opinions
in many cities that we play
so what animals do you still have in the
show lions tigers of Leopard
horses llamas alpacas dogs donkeys goats
and even a kangaroo how do you respond
to your critics what I can tell you is
that our animals are so well cared for
and we have the most dedicated team of
animal care specialists so I think that
you know it's a great offering that we
have and you know it's it's something
that I think families do really cherish
about our show you know Ringling
Brothers has always brought people
together there's something for every one
of the circus
they think it's the greatest show on
earth
you